thanks Jeff President Trump is fighting
back against a special counsel who is
taking over the Russia investigation the
president said yesterday the appointment
of former FBI director robert muller
quote hurts our country terribly he
claimed to chose a de very divided
country
president Trump leaves today for his
first foreign trip in office he lands in
Saudi Arabia tomorrow over the next week
he will also visit Israel the Vatican
Brussels and Sicily Margaret Brennan
will be traveling with the president but
right now she's at the White House
Margaret good morning good morning well
at a sometimes chaotic joint press
conference with Colombia's President
President Trump described himself as a
victim of a witch hunt there was no
collusion and everybody even my enemies
have said there is no collusion
President Trump said the appointment of
special counsel Robert Muller who is now
leading the FBI probe into Russian
election meddling is dividing the
country I respect the move but the
entire thing has been a witch hunt and
there is no collusion between certainly
myself and my campaign but I can always
speak for myself and the Russians zero
the president sharply dismissed
Democrats claims that he may have
interfered in the investigation I think
it's totally ridiculous everybody thinks
so
mr. Trump strongly denied ever urging
former FBI director Comey not to pursue
an investigation into former national
security adviser Michael Flynn who had
misled the White House about his
contacts with Russia did you at any time
urge former FBI director James Comey in
any way shape or form to close or to
back down the investigation into Michael
Flynn and also as you know no next
question since dismissing Comey last
week the president has personally
interviewed several potential
replacements he announced Thursday a
decision was comment we're very close to
an FBI director
- on Capitol Hill the possible
nomination of former Senator Joe
Lieberman a Democrat turned independent
is not expected to gain bipartisan
support I think it's a mistake to
nominate anyone who's ever run for
office Lieberman has lost favor with
Democrats in part because of his 2008
presidential campaign endorsement of
Republican Senator John McCain he's one
of the most wonderful men that I have
ever known he has enormous prestige and
affection on both sides of the aisle a
new FBI director could be selected as
soon as today before President Trump
departs on that big international trip
his nine-day five stop visit begins in
Saudi Arabia and it includes a tour of
the world's great three monotheistic
religions so Margaret what are the goals
for this big international trip his
first one well this has been months in
the making and it was intended to really
try to reassure allies that president
Trump's America first policy doesn't
mean abandoning allies and the president
is going to make a big speech in Saudi
Arabia which the White House says is
meant to unite the United States with
its Muslim allies against extremism but
the president will also then go on to
Italy and to Belgium will he he will
face some tough questions about plans to
increase troop levels in Afghanistan and
whether he will stick with some of those
international agreements like the Iran
nuclear accord and the Paris climate
change agreement and so far the
president doesn't have solid answers to
those questions because the policies are
still being formed
Margaret thanks